hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today is Thursday so that's
another Dempster roof cap for all of you
today with two really quick things
before we start one thing for the next
seven to eight months though it's a
pretty long time the dev stream recap
videos I will be doing I'm gonna be
uploaded a little bit later than they
usually will be like as of like this
summer the only reason is because I'm
starting school next week and it's gonna
be my senior year though so once it hits
June I'll finally be done with high
school and then we'll be back to normal
either way there just be about an hour
later than normal but hopefully that you
guys don't mind but going into the
second topic speaking of dead stream
there will be a dev stream on Monday
instead of Thursday I don't know if
there's going to be two in one week but
they but the devs are going to pax so
they're gonna be having a panel it's
gonna be live streamed once again I'll
still cover it so be on the lookout for
Monday for another dev stream recap B
the way now that we're done let's get
right into it so first up the weekly
content for this week is the smoke
effect for all the new heroes previously
all the DLC character the two DLC
characters had it so now all the heroes
have it and I'll show that to you right
now
[Music]
those are gonna be costing 5,000 steals
so if you'd like that smoke effect you
can go buy that right now there's also a
live update which comes with character
patches including a Highlander guard
break range is now similar to all the
same characters there was a problem with
Highlander where his GB range was super
short centurions heavy in charged heavy
attacks now cost more stamina when
fainted Raider Stampede charge sprint
speed requirement has been increased
from three to four seconds and the start
of time is gone from 600 milliseconds to
700 milliseconds shinobi sprint tackle
requirement hasn't been increased from
three to five seconds
conker no longer falls when hit by a
melee move when in revenge mode upon
activation and Ken says unlock attack is
now being patched and finally the duel
tournament is now alive by the time I'm
making this update so hop on and enjoy
the tournament these patches were
mentioned last week but I thought I'd
recap it for the people that a didn't
either see it N+ it was last week and
added remembers what happened last week
so I thought I'd do that anyway and plus
the patches out right now so either way
continuing on champion status is now 50%
off for every single purchase such as
one month one year and all the others in
between it's gonna be happening all week
so be sure to buy that while you can and
level up some new heroes and new
characters that you haven't played yet
next up they brought up rahman and
damien to answer some questions they had
that the community had and I thought I'd
summarize that for you so first up time
snap will be addressed on why it was
removed and what removing it actually
does in the next couple weeks if you
don't know what time Snap is you can
just go on the competitive for on or
reddit it's all over the damn place I
don't really know how else to explain
that anyway the reworking the old
characters that need buffs like samurai
characters in conqueror but there was no
confirmed date yet they have been saying
this for a couple months but they are
obviously working on the defensive meta
next up they fixed a bug where assassins
could counter a high language crushing
counter-strike moves so I'm glad that
that's fixed and the and then they're
thinking of balancing Centurion again in
4v4 modes because he's a pretty big
threat in a gank situation and a lot of
the community as it is like as a
disliking toward him my only issue with
him though is the amount of damage he
could pull off of a parry
but once again that's just me I don't
know how you guys feel about it let me
know in the comments below what you guys
think about it
about the duel tournament because it
should be up at some of making this
video either way guys that was basically
the end of the video once again it's
another short dev stream next week we
might have some more options or more
patch notes and stuff like that once
again I'll keep you up to date so be
sure to look out on Monday for all that
I hope you guys do enjoy the video
though and if you did leave a like on
this video and then subscribe for more
for on our content if you're a new
coming in the future my newest videos
will be popping on screen now for you to
check out if you missed those and with
all that guys I'll see you later
peace out